Before we say goodbye,
we wanna play a quick round of!
Drewth or Dare!
(audience cheers)
All right, Jackie Schlein.
Hi Jackie.
(indistinct)
Look how cute you look.
Very aligned, bow, blouse.
Mm-hmm.
I style after you, that was the plan.
Oh my God, even the hair is right.
(audience claps)
I know, I can totally see you in that.
Hash tag, twinning.
Cute. All right, what's it gonna be, Jackie?
Is it a Drewth or a dare?
I'm gonna go with a Drewth.
Ooh.
Okay.
Okay, so my question is,
what is the most embarrassing text you've ever sent?
(audience laughs)
One time, I was put in charge of putting together
a dinner party with friends,
and I invited everybody,
and I invited the wrong people.
(audience and Drew laugh)
And rather than tell them, like,
"Oops, I didn't mean to invite you,"
I just let them come.
And guess what? It was a huge hit.
And now we're all friends.
(audience claps)
But oopsie, my bad. But it worked.
Well, I like your text mishap, Ross.
Yeah, (indistinct).
Did you ever admit to any of them?
No, they're probably watching right now.
And they have no idea it's them.
Nope, and welcome to the family.
(audience laughs)
All right, well thank you so much everybody
for choosing to spend your time with us.
We all make this show for you.
So take it with you.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)